donald trump hat gerade der welt den
handelskrieg erklärt mit strafzöllen zum
beispiel auf stahl aus der eu mal
abwarten wie das jetzt eskaliert diese
woche hat der präsident der usa uns in
sachen waffenrecht verblüfft nach dem
schrecklichen amoklauf von florida
deutet sich da möglicherweise eine
vorsichtige wende an
derselbe donau dennoch vor einem jahr
per dekret dafür gesorgt hat dass
psychisch kranke wieder waffen kaufen
dürfen sagt jetzt ohne rot zu werden
leute leute hört bitte auf diesen
psychos waffen zu geben warum macht ihr
das denn ich glaube er weiß nicht mehr
was er letztes jahr gemacht hat ist das
der dank für die 30 millionen dollar mit
denen die waffenlobby nr
trumps wahlkampf unterstützt hat seine
180 grad wende diese woche verdanken wir
natürlich diesen großartigen schüler die
seit wochen für schärfere waffengesetze
demonstrieren die nicht locker lassen
weil sie irgendwann mal ohne todesangst
in die schule gehen wollen
naja vielleicht hat der park and high
school amoklauf wirklich mal was
verändert eine tragödie die vermeidbar
gewesen wäre also nicht durch weniger
waffen sagt schramm
aber wenn er an dem tag die schule
bewacht hätte absolut absolut wäre da
reingegangen
da hat er erstmal wir lagen ja
vorgeschickt aber er wäre eingegangen
der donut muss man wissen ist ja von
natur aus mutig sagt er oft genug
bewiesen wie hier als in dieser fiese
adler angegriffen
und der vogel war noch nicht mal
bewaffnet es bewegt sich langsam was in
den usa und es wird höchste zeit allein
in diesem jahr gab es schon 18 vorfälle
mit schusswaffen an amerikanischen
schulen
deswegen will der präsident ja auch
lehrer bewaffnen ja eine knaller idee
wenn ich bedenke wie mein
geschichtslehrer früher den overhead
projektor bedient hat ja das wird super
eine weitere trump idee er sagt rund 20
prozent der lehrer die talentierten 20
prozent sollen eine wumme kriegen und
das total praktisch auch im normalen
schulalltag meine falls im lehrerzimmer
mal wieder die würfel aus sind als
praktischer kreide halter oder hier
einfach mal zum entspannten einer grauen
in der fünf minuten pause
ja
möglicherweise kommt bewegung rein
vielleicht in linx waffen erst ab 21
will mir leider ganz sicher die nrw gibt
noch lange nicht auf denn denen geht es
schließlich um knallharte
wirtschaftsinteressen die energie haben
über fünf millionen mitglieder geld ohne
ende und einen charismatischen führer
der vorsitzende
wayne lapierre das wussten sie gar nicht
das wussten sie gar nicht gott
persönlich hat den amis ihre waffen
gegeben
überlegen sie mal wenn jesus ein
sturmgewehr gehabt hätte wäre ostern
völlig anders verlaufen als beispiele
ich muss zugeben diese bibel kann die
noch gar nicht aber comcom oper wayne
ist ja nur der vorsitzende das
eigentliche gesicht erinnere ist
[Musik]
natürlich sie braucht waffen den sich
seine mutter einem arm
denn als pin up girl und sprecherin der
nrw
und wenn sie zu hause sagen hat diese
doofen amis bin ich froh dass wir so was
bei uns nicht haben darf ich sie ganz
kurz mit der german rifle association
bekannt machen
gibt es wirklich die stellt auf ihrer
homepage deutsche politiker namentlich
an den pranger
die sich mal kritisch über waffen äußern
und machen direkt alarm wenn irgendein
waffengesetz verschärft werden soll